through the day they have been waiting
for the waters to recede for a chance to
assess the damage to their homes beyond
in this corner of new jersey there are
communities cut off and people stranded
[Music]
she's trying to find a car to see if she
can stay in a car in the night melissa
castro's grandmother lives beyond the
water
alicia castro is 66 and stuck i heard
that there was like people like getting
out in rafts and stuff but like i don't
know how she didn't manage to get out i
mean she's an elder person so
you must be worried i am very worried
and like
it's horrible
i'm sorry
the raritan river has burst its banks at
points along its course it's one of
three in the state overwhelmed locals
here have experienced this before and
yet federal flood protection measures
over the years and buyouts of land have
failed to protect the community against
the volume and the regularity of it all
well the runoff here in manville new
jersey is still significant and it will
be for some time to come and the really
striking thing is that in the northeast
of the country a thousand miles from the
deep south where ida hit as a hurricane
and the damage here is as great in parts
greater than it was in the south and the
loss of life has been worse
across several american states emergency
services have been stretched to their
limits
rescuing people who had retreated up the
top floors of many homes were the only
safe place
people were ferried to drier ground
through the morning whole families young
and old
this is elizabeth new jersey in a glance
now and you'd think that nothing had
happened but look more closely because
just hours ago this was a torrent of
water all these cars had water high up
on their sides the houses all around are
flooded as well an extraordinary level
of water over such a short period of
time a long line of evacuees now wait to
be re-homed
this is my first time ever experiencing
anything like this
so how are you feeling
um i'm a little bit scared
pretty full-on right yeah
but the cat's all right yep she's crying
and this wasn't just rainfall
even having traveled across north
america ida was still producing winds
strong enough to do this a tornado
taking away the only cover some
residents had this is hillsborough to
the south west of new york city
the storm has swept out into the
atlantic but the damage to homes and
infrastructure will take considerable
time to fix
mark stone sky news in new jersey